so check it out this is what we would
refer to as a six beat Fountain and this
is what we would refer to as a fourbe
fountain six
beats four beats what's the difference
is it just splitting hairs or is there
actually something here that would be
good for people in the PO world to know
that is the question I got on a recent
short that I posted so I now expanding
the subject into its own video
Drex here from Drex Factor po sharing
with you the love of Po spinning and
flow Arts to benefit your body and brain
and today we're diving into the
differences between six and four beat
fountains and we're going to discover
some other cool things along the way too
but before we dive in I just want to
give a quick shout out to the Friends of
the channel big thanks to dark monk fire
Mecca flow fests flow toys pyro Tera
light toys and Ultra poy for helping to
make the videos on this channel possible
you can learn more about all these
awesome companies and the work they're
doing to support flow artists like
yourself by checking out the links down
in the description of this video and
special thanks to the non-b business
friend of the channel Becca beckon thank
you so much for supporting my channel my
work and my mission okay so first we
have to talk a little bit about what a
fountain even is and when we refer to a
fountain I think what we're really doing
is we're giving shorthand to any of a
type of Po trick that involve a level
change that takes us out of the world of
just taking a weave back and forth
across our bodies in a waist strap like
this and bringing some element of it up
around our shoulders whether that
element happens to go behind our
shoulders or it doesn't both seem to
register as something that we think of
with that label Fountain uh but what
actually up being the difference between
the different approaches to doing that
now let's take a look at what I believe
was the first fountain that was ever
identified which is based upon a waist
strap that is taking just a weave back
and forth between the reverse and
forwards turning it across our body like
so and if I take one hand and po out of
it you'll see that the motion of just
doing this with one hand I wind up doing
1 2 3 4 five six down beats with just
one POI and of course both poy are doing
this at the same time as we're going I
always have my forwards weave on my
right and my reverse weave on my left
well not always but it's the way I'm
most comfortable doing it now you notice
that as I'm taking that weave back and
forth across my body my hands are
basically traveling in a straight line
that is about even with the bottom of my
rib cage that's that's pretty common for
most folks but the thing is that line
doesn't have to stay a straight line in
fact when I'm going from my forwards
weave to my reverse weave I can instead
of taking it across the line of my rib
cage take it down and around past my
hips it's only a minor tweak and then
when I take it back over to the forwards
weave on my stage right I take it up and
over past my face down and around past
my hips up and over past my face it's
funny but watching the old tutorials and
demonstrations on home of poy remember
seeing the video of the fountain and not
being it all clear of what was going on
there just having like some awareness of
the fact that it was basically a waist
strap but that there was a level change
involved taking it both down low as well
as up high and really what this does is
it turns the waist strap into something
approximating a flower where now we have
the POI in hands both moving around in a
circle so I want to point something out
here right quick because it will become
important for things we discussed later
on and that is that if we look at this
move from the side you'll note that in
all of those spots where I'm taking my
hands and PO either up and over or down
and under both my hands and my POI are
in front of me at all times the only
times when the POI cross around back
past the plane of my shoulders is when
they're on either
side of that weave SL Fountain and this
is actually really important important
and really useful because it means that
when going across the middle section
there I am not actually beholden to
making sure that I always make the same
choice so here's here's what I mean by
that as I'm performing my forwards weave
over here on stage right and taking it
over to my reverse weave on stage left
the convention that I've adopted is that
I'm going to take my hands down and
around but because my hands and poy are
always in front of me as I'm doing that
I don't have to take it down and around
instead I could take it up and over make
a different choice but really it's that
same waist strap we played around with
to start with I'm just reversing my
choices here so that I wind up taking
that Fountain around in an anti-spin
Direction and likewise when I'm coming
from my reverse weave to my forwards
weave like so I can choose to instead of
taking it up and over I can instead
choose to take it down and around so
long as my hands and POI are always in
front of me and that middle section I
have the option of choosing whether I go
up or whether I go down and I can change
that choice any old time I want it makes
it really easy to switch back and forth
between these different ways of
Performing the fountain in spin and
anti-spin and because this Fountain is
based on performing a waist strap and as
we discussed earlier there are six beats
in the waist strap this likewise we
would refer to as a six beat Fountain
again count him as we go along here
following the orange po I count 1 2 3 4
5 6 1 2 3 4 five 6 beats as I take the
PO all the way around here and of course
the yellow PO is doing the exact same
thing just slightly displaced a little
bit in space but it's the same number of
Beats but of course the first fountain
that I actually learned as a PO spinner
is something that I didn't think of as a
fountain at all when I first learned it
and that was the four-beat fountain
because in my mind what this actually
was was taking a away strap and then
transitioning into a windmill up top in
fact I thought of this as being the
first transition that I ever learned how
to do with Po and I was very proud of
myself for learning how to do it for the
first time each of those individual
tricks didn't just sit alone in their
own boxes they were things that could be
attached to each other and things that
you could move back and forth between
but of course when you move continuously
through this pattern uh you wind up with
something that does discreetly look like
its own trick and uh I got into the
habit of referring to it as a four-beat
fountain uh from Nick Woolsey he was the
first person that I saw refer to it in
that fashion but just like we did with
our six beat Fountain we can very easily
see how we get 1 2 3 4 beats one 2 3
four beats as we go around with each
hand um needless to say there are some
differences between this and the six
beat Fountain but uh the biggest
difference is not that we dropped two
beats the biggest difference is that
we've kind of fundamentally changed the
structure of the fountain now remember
when I was playing around with the six
beat Fountain here how we have these
sections where we're going across from
the forwards to the reverse weave when
both our hands and our poy are out in
front of us when we switch over to doing
a fourbe fountain all of a sudden the
top part of that disappears and now when
we're going across the top we are
dropping both Po and hands behind our
shoulders as we go over top so six beat
Fountain my hands and poer in front of
me four beat Fountain they go behind my
uh shoulders and my head as I'm going
across the top part of it here now it
creates a really distinctive and
interesting looking pattern of course
where uh I seem to be constantly having
the Poise swirl around me like so uh and
I think one thing I really love doing
actually is making the transition from
six beat fountain down to four beat
Fountain because I feel like it adds
some excitement to it and then of course
I can go down to a windmill and I've
come to a place where I've just built up
a moment of tension that I can then
release by finishing with something like
a spiral wrap but there are also some
other important properties of fourbe
fountains that we should dive into as
well so fourbe fountains have long been
kind of challenging for me to wrap my
mind around because I really think that
they kind of behave like almost a
mutated version of a fountain a couple
other things that are all slapped
together and that means that they don't
behave like any one kind of pyric they
have qualities of multiple different
pyric all kind of slapped together and
one of the biggest differences uh is
just like right from the drop
now there's actually no place in this
move where you drop fully into a 3B
weave when you're over on the forward
side on your left here uh you're doing a
two beat with your right hand on top
going forwards and then you swap to a
two beat with your right hand on bottom
your left hand on top over here on the
left side with the PO going reverse and
then you pop up into the windmill so
when I come back over onto my forward
side my left hand automatically goes
under my right there is never a point
where I go over and then under in order
to get here I'm only doing under and
then back out under and then back out
and windmill so fundamentally the
structure is very very different than um
a six beat Fountain and in fact um uh
Ivan Mel gorinov the uh very famous
Russian spinner has a completely
different way of thinking about this he
actually thinks of these four-beat
fountains as being a version of a 4be
windmill above the head that we're just
displacing elements of to from side to
side uh and I see where he's coming from
on this because yes there are elements
of it that like geometrically work out
to be the same you can see that if we
just focus on where the hands wind up as
we're going back and forth with this
then yes of course the pattern is almost
identical to a 4be fountain I'm not sure
that I find this framing of it helpful
for my own spinning if for no other
reason then I don't think it makes it
easier to learn and I don't really get
the gist from it that it connects
together several other dots but you
might find that formulation useful for
yourself so I'm putting it in here
nonetheless and of course one of the
biggest and probably the most obnoxious
byproducts of having to work with a
fourbe fountain in the same way that we
think of a six beat Fountain is that the
six beat fountains leave us an easy way
to switch back and forth between
anti-spin and ins spin because once
again in those spots where we're going
down and around or up and over the hands
and poy are always in front of us so we
have the option of switching back and
forth quite easily that's not true in
fourbe fountains because we have the top
part that goes around our head like so
we have to make some really specific
choices about what we're going to
consider fair game if we try and take
this into an anti-spin
Direction so like to me I consider the
most important elements of this being
that we have moments on bottom where we
have the left hand go behind the right
hand go behind and then when we go up
top left behind right behind so the
hands Alternate which one go behind it
in a given time and of course we still
have to do the thing where we have the
POI go around our heads like so this is
kind of how I have been performing it
but I don't think that it's necessarily
a perfect conversion uh in talking with
Mel about his interpretation of fourbe
fountains he certainly thinks that it's
just frankly impossible to do an
anti-spin 4be Fountain and given the
lens that he's looking at it through I
would agree uh certainly the elements
that he considers to be valid for
putting together a fourbe fountain
completely forbid the possibility of
doing it anti-spin because it would mean
our hands would have to go through our
bodies in order to attain it or of
course we could do some weird like
inverted version of it that goes through
the hands but um I don't have arms
flexible enough to do that unfortunately
okay so I'm going to throw one more
curveball at you and that is to tell you
that there's actually another 4 beat
Fountain and this one actually does have
an easy anti-spin variation and if you
play around with meteors you've probably
already done it see we do a thing when
we play around with meteor where we have
uh a weave with the two po spinning
around in one hand like so now the thing
is I'm always leading this meteor weave
with my thumb end it is always my orange
poy that goes back and forth and I could
just as easily think of this as being a
TW beat weave where I always have my
right hand POI leading going back and
forth like so now the thing is we do
have a version of the uh waist trrap and
of course the fountain that we can do
with
our hands in a 2.1 hand kind of
situation where we're going back and
forth between two beat weaves the way we
do it is we go from having our uh kind
of thumb Le version over here on the
right to a pinky Le version over here on
the left going back and forth between
them we have to perform a little linear
isolation to get back and forth
like so but this is basically two two
beat weaves that are stuck together and
you can count the beats with me here the
red one or I should say the orange one
goes around 1 2 3 4 1 2 3 four times
four be weave so if we do this with both
hands we wind up in a
place where this
becomes our waist strap with these two
beat weaves switching back and forth
between a a right- hand lead weave and a
left-and lead weave and guess what if we
want to we can also turn this into a
fountain both in ins spin as well as an
anti-spin Fountain like
so now you may be asking yourself what
makes this Fountain markedly different
from the other fourbe fountain that we
have been looking at so far and aside
from the fact that it does the same
thing that our six beat Fountain does
where we have the moments when the poy
are going from side to side always in
front of us rather than behind us
allowing us to make an easy switch
between anti-spin and ins
spin um but also too there's a very very
subtle shift between this version of a
fourbe fountain
and this version of a fourbe fountain um
namely there's a little moment
when I'm going across the bottom here in
the 4B Fountain uh namely the the
version that is similar to the 6B where
I can easily switch back and forth
between ins Spin and anti-spin um where
I have to like kind of pop one po out of
the way for a second to allow the other
one to lead and that doesn't happen in
the other version in the other version
I'm basically making it so that the
right hand poy leads all the way over to
to the other side it's acting like it
wants to become a three beat weave over
here on my left side but I'm just simply
not allowing it instead of completing
that I'm popping up into that windmill
to complete my uh fourbe Fountain here
so to me that says that we have two
different fourbe fountains one of which
actually works very very close to the
six beat Fountain and one of which seems
to be this kind of Frankenstein of
different elements that are all stuck
together um um and could very well be a
variation on a 4be windmill if we want
to take a look at it that way so where
does that leave us with our breakdown of
fountains well I think then of there
being basically two categories of
fountains one that I refer to as the
true fountains and the other one that I
refer to as the false or the pseudo
fountains um the true fountains are all
based in weaves and specifically in
Waist straps and those waist straps have
to be symmetrical that is as I'm
performing my six beat waist strap right
here going back and forth between three
beat weaves I'm always doing so in a
fashion where both the POI and my hands
are in front of me as I'm going across
the middle this allows me to take the
motion around either in spin or
anti-spin very very easily and likewise
I have access to a 4 beat waist strap
that is two 2 beat weaves stuck together
like so that likewise anytime I'm going
across the middle section here I can
take it around either anti-spin or I can
take it around inpin in fact I would say
that the capacity to be able to easily
switch back and forth between inpin and
antipin is a diagnostic characteristic
of these true fountains um should also
be said we also have this option when
we're playing around with five beat
weaves going back and forth across our
bodies like so once again we can take
the bottom part and we can take the top
part and we can do them both in spin and
anti-spin because they have the middle
section going across the front of
us and then there are the false or
pseudo fountains and the fourbe fountain
definitely fits into that category for
me uh a because it is very very
difficult if not impossible to take it
back anti-spin and also to because it is
not a move wherein we have a clean uh
weave on either side of our body we're
we're not just constructing it
completely out of weaves there's
something else that happens across the
top and whether you want to think of it
as a false fountain or a uh variation on
the fourbe windmill hey I I'm not here
to judge you but it does make me curious
if there are other false fountains out
there so maybe you can find some
examples I haven't found a lot just yet
but uh I also haven't done a lot of
looking just yet either so maybe you can
beat me there either way this is a fun
topic to explore I hope you uh enjoyed
going down the rabbit hole with me today
uh thanks to poy Peter for requesting
this video and giving me an opportunity
to uh wax a little nerdy about po
fountains did you get anything out of
this video please make sure to like
share comment and subscribe keep the
conversation going and help my channel
grow thanks a lot
this video and all the videos on my
channel would not be possible without my
amazing supporters on patreon in
particular I'd love to give a shout out
to my flow patrons who are listed on
screen right now thank you all so much
you rock and if you out there watching
are not currently supporter but you like
the content that I create you like
seeing videos about po spinning and flow
arts and you'd like to see more of them
the best way that you can ensure that
that's going to happen is to sign up to
support the work that I do over on
patreon uh specifically at
patreon.com Factor poy there you can get
access to some amazing rewards but even
better than that you'll be helping me
out in my mission of bring po spinning
and flow Arts to the whole wide world so
go check that out please and thank you
and if you'd like to learn more about
fountains you can check out this video
right here that I did on fountains a
little while back this is a topic that
I've explored several times on this
channel and it's a really fun one I have
to say I'll go ahead and link to it up
on screen as well as down in the
description thank you all so much for
watching make sure to get out and flow
today and I'll see you with a new video
very very soon take care now peace